get the basketball through the
basketball hoop you may not touch the
basketball with your hands you may not
wear gloves or anything that could
reasonably be construed to be gloves
fast this land
your time startsnow okay I see could it
be something else that like if I take
okay well good I'm doing it okay that's
the thing it's like it's so easy and you
see people doing it all the time using
hands and I figured you're a creative
lot and certainly there must be a
workaround I'm going to show you how two
of these guys the each end of the row
Dylan and Ron first let's try it
yep nope man that's trim okay let me go
to my shed okay ready to play basketball
[Music]
[Applause]
come on piece of here we go right
here grandma shot okay that was so close
damn back with a fire pole will clarify
here we go daddy's home
[Applause]
[Music]
a lot of passion yeah a lot of anger
yeah yeah a little anger you were
disappointed in yourself although few
times two times how long did he take -
right yes he villain doesn't prompt yes
yes cousin Francis the producer and DJ
yes producer and DJ yeah Dylan took 2
minutes and 11 seconds it's pretty quick
run methodical yeah well I pretty much
had the same skill level of basketball
with my hands are a flower fire that
explains a lot so I'm new to this
country I didn't realize people could
walk that slowly to a shed but Braun
took the same amount of attempts as
Dylan but he took a little bit longer he
took 8 minutes under an hour under an
hour you have any more videos of other
people just warming that hassle I got
two more the perfect couple least
reprise maybe get use it as a football
you know what do I do
do I have to go in there and get it what
I don't want to get wet you go chefs
what's it okay hold on ivory where the
is
yeah you cut out all of the bad attempt
oh yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Music]
okay
[Applause]
[Music]
I'm freaking roll this game bitch
you Lisa hate that guy